with time one thing nothing today
Arthur how do you get football out of coffee
are the and of solidity IPTV are used not
like the 60 conference to press the
presentation of semester programs
could the Portuguese be precise and
concepts how do they need  german
in these the feminist leader in Portugal
wins the coast is appeared Federal the
commission is in Paola's modeling I need
accessories ciliary Secrets there intend
route of the day the important is
equal belonging to the
Portuguese turn preference of Amos contact debated
in plenary EA create Expresso grande  and
shower Neila Nacional de la Presidencia
Portuguesa EA with divider its
priority to have a Europe that the green
that I type that the container and
above all just look at the
reinforcing comics our letter to
identify the frame when touching it and from the
models
the European as  a series of initiatives
that is particularly important in
active having medium and long period of
loves Contract or in the big grand  and
events that coincide with this
stove flame very fiery belonged to the
want AF double helix Tucson And if it in
person andare Avanti per meter
Europe and all that irritates us is that in it to
pack garbage to operate is with that
serious one on top of meeting of the
elaborate m of  thread annual inventory
instrument concentrate because he
subtext of European Union will be
successful of our series seems to ask for
free about president tickets by
president of the let's go there so your
presence too tutanat Natal dir in
plenary to be debated the extract of
Matina for this public est une
their unity.exe the biota
the free how to do the first view
is very good afternoon I wanted to start to
win the present as Cole the welcome
in this Parliament of Cláudia was a member
of which he was already vice president and
once again feel at home  although today
in a New Condition and here I want to
congratulate myself for the great consensus
that I found rudimentary what are
the main priorities  ades of the
Portuguese presidency as pains we know we are currently experiencing
one
of the most dramatic moments of the
pandemic crisis in many countries exactly in
mine but also a new moment of hope
with the start of the affirmation process
is
i am the Raptor we are going
simultaneously a moment that  it is
one of the most dramatic moments of this
pandemic in many countries, exactly
mine but also simultaneously hope
where the start of the vaccination process
on the one hand and on the other hand the agreement
established for the new multiannual financial side
and for the new Next Generation
you are a  door of hope that's why
the motto of our presidency is time to
act time to have a fair recovery
green and digital we have to set in motion
to implement the
decisions taken in recent months that's
why we have three very clear priorities
the first to  economic and
social recovery in Europe second place the
development of pilates Official  of the
European Union and
a place to reinforce the autonomy of
Europe open to the world and when the
first priority That is the priority
of the vaccination plan But also for the
quick approval and setting of the
different national plans of reform
of the it is fundamental that the
national parliaments of Rectification So if possible
the division to increase the
union's own and also were European or
even the new regulation for this
problem is totally in being able to be
totally very horny Professor what
lateral means of political force
what will be the plan  of action that the
commission will soon present in order
to put into practice the 20 main
principles that we already
presented back in
gothenburg  of Europe and this
social dimension is fundamental to give
confidence to the citizen  the companies and
workers the huge challenges is
climate transition EA the digital transition
behaves are supported by sport
investment in
people's skills in business innovation and
social protection that Ensure that no one
is in a hurry and finally just a
more autonomous Europe  and open to the world and
that is why the day on the
wild front is a day on which we see ourselves
hoping for the new framework of
transatlantic relations with the United States
but it is also the day on which I
appealed to the European Parliament to
quickly  approves the agreement signed
several
and the United Kingdom which has become a new
day to continue to be an old ally
And it will certainly be a great partner in the
future and it is also in this 360° vision
that we want to deepen our
partnership relations
strategic ordinance with Africa I used one of the
relations with Latin America but also
being a lucky position in the
Indo-Pacific space  o and that is why we will
organize the summit of the European Union
one day in order to place at the center of
this economic region a strong
partnership between the two largest
democracies in the world of the European Union
and India and it is with great satisfaction that
after this morning's intense debate  With
all Petropolitans represented
in this European Parliament
, I am confident that, in the face of all the
difficulties, political support
is what this
presidency offers and that is why in the next six
months I will be able to help Parliament, the
chairman of the council, Michel and
above all the president of  Commission course
as underlines to lead to good Porto This
enormous work has been doing and
yesterday proved in the midst of the most
terrible crisis that we learned since the end of the
second world war enormous added value
that constitutes the European union and this
added value translated into the  the fact that we have
a joint purchase of vaccines that
ensures that all citizens of Europe do
not have access to vaccines in  on the same
level of equality, but also that we have
the capacity to mobilize resources that
no other state would have in order to provide
a socially robust response to the
economic and social crisis we are experiencing
to recover our our
economies and above all to protect employment
the employment that is  fundamental for the
future of our citizens are obliged
to
There are days when more goes Antônio Oliveira
and Maxwell who publishes an article from the post
this makes us walk from each character
Favorite gadacz there name site the
tax happened and cough is home upon receipt
of the 2016 handout  Portuguese President
we stayed was diesel and pulled with in time
ago is the beautiful fact this floor make one
Hand we see the world is the light
Adriano to the patron Window give to another
news bro sandwich from the Clube
Heart network for 5:00 Hardcore prisms stay or
Elsa  fact we still need love download
Across your people to have one Block
from Love Don't hold you up and his kind
of course if it is n  ecessary but you
can't Miss The High Price is not very
well but I
o Sax di type template our backs
inflation is freakin Sweet about Who's
next in which you will mend is Because
of him out along with his Love demo
important is here home o  Strongest
Man presents Memories and your pingy
you the digitalization and of course
reinforcements EA professor Show Stop para
necessary and Power to meet your house
and Men and Portugal and I don't surf
with right track is necessary in all
variables with black cat in process
Connection  with you and respect each
member state is with you need is now in
economics with Public sector and is a
very Special Day one of those with
Higher in Talismã de Português
Presidente epit
a Very Special Derby couple inauguration
ceremony dar waiting for me and because
of the  End of a very of ict fueron of
United States and now with the United
States to come back and Health
International cooperation so I'm looking
very much Power to present study of
Brain powerful you from Atlantic a
Jennifer Lawrence in Heaven Love Comes
To You And very good at what is coming
back to The International stage for
Adilson Antônio a from a
strength association year from cantinho another client
strength from Fátima Afonso rotated before this
is old imagine  Who is going to try tequila
that I am pause can and know e-mail
sold That's it India with and looking at
the amazing Collection
the option democracy and the world Cell
surfaces and I Remind you of that This
is our song We have so much that her
Missing  out on Hold of you need is a
free download interactive media presence
Of His account And diverse and dynamic
and I hope you switcher Antônio that you
will benefit from your dreams and your
last stand of India and of course and
The International Arena and love and
Life  points and is thought that we have
on tracks with the agreements and media and
of course and it is great you from the
fire and flames and Ends with som de
Born of Hope we Welcom  and as long
Hello I'm Estrada Luiza I swear
by the pirates Rafa you want to take a
shower here so why take it
before this important one go there and so many
even everything he can have stay a
text look at that girl from the clinic there in the
middle  calm down so you can
send it not there if you go after that make the
big one if the guy like Chocolates I
implemented his penguin as many times
Ball I'm the one who rests here now over
here the seed or your oven
is necessary while the class  for the
waters of the sea
the rock parts will also change the
[Music]
And then I hope that doing
Oi Gente will part here is worse than the
little bug over the microphone and eighty
percent of people over 60 years
old in Portugal and others  countries that
this group of older people
those who promise are not miracles
is not a group of the first priority group
and I ask if it will receive the plan of
the Portuguese team taking into account this
professional activity linked
to people we have to  not using the indirect one but it
's funny because even After vaccination doesn't
hit as soon as I did what I'm
angry it leaves the lump like this 97
malvaccini exactly the story
wi-fi signal where does Enzo Mariana sell
that scene that is the animal is who  open
yours to destined the hand just did the other
city french walk the course and your
bulletin perfect and according to Johnson and
Johnson and cure Wax or diamond the
praxis will be Rising Rising and Flying
Birds go to Heaven Where the angels go
to Heaven and  each and every kind of
Mood and percentage of over Eight years
old and End of Summer Seventy percent of
Setúbal they are and fast
length priority group
Health Professionals second
priority group people hospitalized or
residents in nursing homes and concentration that
today we can be sure that by the end
of next week we will have  ensure
full vaccination of all
residents in care homes working in care homes
and then we have the program defined
which combines on the one hand the
risk groups associated with comorbidity that is
other diseases that are known
in the situation has come and also the
age criterion because as we know the
risk ratio to the population at greater
risk in terms of age and the
elderly population over these months
we all have the pra
and the others and it worked out that the
technical committee is Portuguese will also take into
account the  recommendations of the
european commission in the evaluation that was and
evaluating this implies or not a revision of
the defined vaccination criteria we
have our vaccination plan modulated according
to the doses that and the schedule
of distribution of doses in Portugal
was established in the contract between the
european union and the different
production companies and process as
long as this contract is fulfilled
we can fulfill it in the signature  tion
as we have been doing so far
the Next question from denmark at Any rate
book Forest Hills
Andthen
the seventh remote almost as much as it
fits in another phone from there and there
Firefox 57 from VAT from the law exchange where it
does the worst I don't know  I've already managed to
do your tips in terms of
pounds I'm a must listen
to my current phone sex there is
a great offer increase use fifth and let's go
ship from here spiritual that has to
see more healthy and go there fire with a
surprise by the announcement  of the
Beyond that hardly had his Creed II mid
peak hold your Fire and I think He is of
utmost importance At The Stars Are
fixing the country pickles most member
States are stored to vaccinate the first
shot o bairro onde é que vai do and
roll rock  in full is right or so the
next shot has to be applied to his
American in that top part of the skateboard
rockets spoke wrong understands sound
a do with Tony is what the Company said
Love Is Fire and really on What I have 7
p  ublicly and press release of fire is in
fact some of our Country and all I need
this vaccine is now to enable with
transparency to verify the area and
dismiss payment device and
necessary information to continue hand
Natura matter of the system works as
a spirit of collaboration from it to  crisis
in the knife by there facing squeezing
people builds up democracy and what you
love doing because we don't believe
that the crisis of Democracy we can
overcome and corn
is necessary to have payment for your
attività in
o Olá taking the following David frown to
open Italy was delivered  there is a
sister who arrives you must come in a cart not even
there a government that happens I am in
Timor qualified the proposal to
implement Next Generation you is considered a
priority by the presidency for free and
the prime minister
Andthen
the future Italian politician is  the one that
the president of the program that offers the
best conditions than I get very
well you very much  I am satisfied that it was
approved because the
fundamental advantage is that stability in the conduct
of policies in
the European Union member states as a whole And
we can carry out these decisions
that we took last semester for
telling me the intelligent vaccination plan to
prevent  very demanding anemia by
gang of what we see of
economic cooperation are fundamental and therefore
stability is absolutely essential
for the success of the European recovery
in all the 27 member states and certainly not only
in and Italy and
the dream of going to the taxpayer has in
which the  verb civil Crisis and at a time
when installing under time Where you'd
have to join forces to work hard
Possible to get the thrill of the
Standard house mix brings to
YouTube economic crises I committed nem
very Close contact with Kale And
government and  accidents with not much
of Garden the week of NY before ongoing
work at Leader start to change Open member
States should spend on e  volving to make
sure that the worst of punishments video
until the end and level up And let's
join forces in
and it's not quite the thread quietly she doesn't
have italian there italian doesn't answer the
military consultation and with two points
enable clean from the crisis Wicked com
this moment of strength that should continue
tracksuit italian is particularly
here I will have to give you a job is it
worth it or not in a hurry and italian and for
the european church and wanting to cut
responsibility language were account Lab
subject airport commissione
moving away from yours and i stayed want  her
presbyterian known as nose strength
and for Europe she left free wax 1
is the last question a it may be different
for Fernanda Gabrielle RTP Thank you
for the presidency 92/2007 ask
what is the story that will
mark this presidency in
The mother  the crab that all Europeans
want one for the next six months is
that we need to move forward in the 27
member states very strongly in the
vaccination plan, which is an essential condition
for everything else so that we can conclude
all the institutional acts for the
approval of the instruments that allow
this historic gesture that the creation
of a recovery and resilience plan
can effectively
begin to have
concrete translation during the Portuguese presence  in transfers
to companies for the citizen to
revive the European economy and We would
like this presidency to result,
not now in Lisbon but now in Porto, in
a very strong declaration about a
commitment by all of us to the
development of the social pillar of
Europe and the establishment of a  new
partnership with india
and bora a jaundice we next time you i
went two with her or volcanic Standard
or superior all meatloaf Next
Generation and people Will start
implementing of Plants that is the bust
of investment in your name come to be
Born is  so I love it is Within Days with
essays from the board of Heart next week
and I
The Island has the minister Costa in the hearts
is not attracting protagonisti
European policy even in contract and
European event is withdrawn a
protagonist of the European response
and in the huge one for which the change of January
to create a column in the question very
difficult very complicated makeup of the
tuf of the Okay vitamin and European Union
is useful Alô Vita
is incredible that it costs to continue ok And there in the
Presidente da Portuguesa there I naturally find one
because they had heard Júnior
in which he develops policy in April
there was June and calls for an invitation or what to
hear her prioritize from him  piracitrus close
respond to the requirements and read qst of
93 citadini of which pants he found not
worried right that she is usually sanitary
he got only allovita guard
he washed is whatever in them post
his Europe will be in the decisive power Earth
sent that European Union in him
here to  from there empower and insert the
list of anything brought to
initiates or thread important back
moment  of great difficulty it
is ethical pity yes remember the
Ethere
[Music]